aber über die inhalte müssen wir
natürlich sprechen zusammen mit
professor stephan fröhlich
politikwissenschaftler für
internationale politik an der
universität erlangen hat der professor
frische montag
habe ich was überhört oder war da nicht
viel neues dabei also zumindest im teil
der der pressekonferenz wo beide
minister erst mal ihre statements
abgegeben haben muss ich sagen glaube
ich haben sie nicht zugehört ich habe
einen einzigen nebensatz gehört wo es um
die frage ging wie reagieren wie er oder
wie können wir reagieren ist es in frage
und antwort teil dann etwas deutlicher
geworden und da hieß es einmal von der
ministerin auch unter inkaufnahme
eigener wirtschaftlicher einschränkungen
wenn es um das thema sanktionen geht und
da bin ich einmal hellhörig geworden
ansonsten war es die klare ja weil es
das ist das einzige was mich bis dato so
stückweit aufgeweckt hat so werden
deutschland werden konkreter
wir werden konkreter dass hier das
einhellige signal ausgesandt wird das
positive teil ist also das ist das
positive was man sagen kann über diese
pressekonferenz wir ziehen tatsächlich
an einem strang
sprich amerika und europa stehen
zusammen wir europäer untereinander
haben die größeren abstimmungsprobleme
als im im
konzert mit den vereinigten staaten
zumindest vordergründig hat das design
und hinter den kulissen ist man in
washington auch deutlicher übrigen was
den instrumentenkasten aber lang wie
können wir darauf reagieren was die so
genannten roten linien anbelangt das ist
ja es insofern als man da konkreter
anspricht als man sie getan hat das
thema wirtschaftssanktionen das thema
nord stream zwei das thema
waffenlieferungen das was wir sozusagen
im köcher erhalten für uns und es ist
erstaunlich
es zeigt im grunde genommen eine
supermacht eine weltmacht die
vereinigten staaten
sagen wir mal mit mit leisen tönen die
bereitschaft in washington
sich für die ukraine und für europa ich
sage mir jetzt etwas salopp ins zeug zu
legen die hält sich in grenzen die ist
da die ist da diese solidarität aber die
erwartung ist in washington dass die
europäer so naja leisten und mehr machen
lassen sie mich das verstehen das heißt
also sie sagen im endeffekt müssten die
europäer eigentlich mit ihrem jedoch
reduzierten militär arsenal eigentlich
mehr druck ausüben weil die amerikaner
mit ihrem großen militärpotenzial
eigentlich gar nicht so richtig lust
haben diesen druck aus also ich würde
mal sagen was die militärische
abschreckung anbelangt ist amerika schon
bereit aber eben nur unter der
voraussetzung und das ist wichtig dieses
signal zu verstehen dass die europäer
eben auch ihren angemessenen teil dazu
beitragen in den beiden anderen bereiche
wenn es um wirtschaftssanktionen geht
wenn es um das thema nord stream 2 geht
liegt der ball ohnehin bei uns wenn man
sich einmal das sind themen die werden
dabei immer ausgeblendet wenn man sich
das verhältnis russlands und vereinigten
staaten die wirtschaftsbeziehungen
anschaut der handelsaustausch da ist
nicht viel also ich mache natürlich
können die amerikaner traditionen
auferlegen natürlich kann man vor allem
über die schärfste waffe des swift die
von den amerikanern kontrolliert wird am
ende des tages natürlich kann man da
etwas bewirken aber dies das will keiner
ziehen im moment diese diese diese diese
sagen wir mal optionen ansonsten dass
nämlich das kurz fragen warum nicht weil
gerade das swift abkommen das klingt
meine damen und herren jetzt
wahrscheinlich sehr bürokratisch aber da
geht es im endeffekt um überweisungen
die im internationalen finanzsystem dann
gestaltet werden und der professor
fröhlich wenn man da ansetzen würde wäre
russland ja enorm ist betroffen weil
daneben die gelder nicht mehr so nach
außen keine frage setzt man da nicht die
wahl weil es den europäern eben auch
gravierend wehtut ganz einfach
insbesondere in dem bereich das muss man
sagen bis jetzt ist ja von den
wirtschaftssanktionen der bereich gas öl
etc der sektor weit es geht noch
ausgenommen worden das hat etwas damit
zu tun das ist der eigennutz das ist das
interesse natürlich insbesondere auch
der bundesrepublik deren abhängigkeit
vom gas aus russland noch mal ungleich
größer ist als im eu schnitt aber auch
da ist die abhängigkeit groß und das
betrifft uns dann eben auch ich meine
wenn trifft aus dann wenn zwölft
ausgesetzt wird heißt das eben auch für
uns dass wir im grunde genommen wenn wir
dass wir unser gas nicht mehr bezahlen
können wir wissen nicht wie russland
darauf reagiert dass sind denke das muss
man sich technisch einfach erst mal
vorstellen was das heißt das heißt je
steckt wirklich sehr viel sprengstoff
drin nochmals für die amerikaner ist es
weniger problematisch weil er weniger
abhängigkeiten sind als für uns europäer
deswegen muss man eben sehen wo können
wir tatsächlich ansetzen und reagieren
swift ist eine sehr harte waffe und
würde uns sehr betreffe neben
gleichermaßen aber es gibt andere dinge
unterhalb dieser schwelle und es gibt
natürlich tatsächlich am realistischsten
trotz allem den bereich
waffenlieferungen auch als signal
gegenüber der ukraine das dürfen wir
nicht vergessen dass ich alles gibt es
gibt nord stream zwei das ist überhaupt
keine frage dass steht eben natürlich
trotz allem auf der agenda das hat ja
auch mittlerweile unser bundeskanzler
so haben wir mal ein stück weit durch
eine wollte und kurswechsel
signalisiert dass das auch eine option
ist und darum jedes eigentlich mehr kann
der westen tatsächlich auch nicht machen
es gibt keine andere lösung daher völlig
die waffenlieferung sind ja gab es ja
heute auch noch mal eine nachricht also
dass joe biden da auch sozusagen
zugestimmt hat großbritannien und auch
estland lettern glitter und dürfen
waffen die aus den usa kommen liefern an
die ukraine die mode also zugestimmt die
wochenzeitung die zeit die stellt heute
eine frage die ich gerne weitergeben
will nämlich die frage was will
eigentlich putin und wenn ich diese
pressekonferenz meine damen und herren
eben beobachtet habe dann schätze ich
mir doch die frage ist so wirkt für mich
so als wenn eben der westen wartet was
macht eigentlich putin und da stellt
sich dann die frage was will er
eigentlich soll das frage ich meine
sitzt was grunde genommen im moment
würde ich sagen tatsächlich am längeren
hebel er diktiert die agenda einmal mehr
und er tut es im grunde und seit 2014
und das ist zum teil unserer uneinigkeit
geschulter schuldet insofern war das ein
wichtiges signal zumindest zu hören dass
der westen hier an einem strang sieht
weiters gehen aber auch die frage ist
auf welcher ebene wie weit geht diese
bereitschaft und mit welcher
reagieren wir und es ist schon
interessant zu hören dass ja auch
gestern den letzten tagen deutlich
geworden im grunde genommen die
sanktionen das womit gedroht wird das
greift wenn ein einmarsch erfolgt
eigentlich ist die jetzige situation
schon anlass genug was russland den
letzten zwei tagen und wochen tut ist
sowohl im fall belarus in diesem fall so
polnische grenze sowohl mit blick auf
die cyberaktivisten aktivitäten die
blinken ja angesprochen hat das ist
alles das das weiß man verfolgt diese
aktivitäten das ist mit blick auf den
aufmarsch der in der an der grenze zur
ukraine
gleichzeitig redet man von entspannung
und hat das geschehen lassen und wir
lassen es wäre wie wir haben wir stehen
zusammen stückweit ohnmächtig da schaut
es an und sagen die rote linie besteht
wenn jetzt ist zum übergriff kommt dann
dann reagieren wir die frage ist ob es
nicht schon längst zweites zu reagieren